so something that's going on this summer
which I do not support is salt and straw
the ice cream place from Portland which
is partially owned by Dwayne The Rock
Johnson has lost their mind
these are some of their flavors this
summer chocolate potato salad
spiced mustard ice cream potato chip
cookies fudge what the is going on
Dwayne Johnson and the lesbian
wiccans that own salt and straw baked
brie and fig cheesecake pre-chees cake
ice cream candied Rich crackers thick
fig Jam what's happening
cinnamon and honey Fried Chicken served
by whites
spiced vanilla ice cream bits of fried
chicken croissant
so I now here at the Timberland show I'm
gonna try these flavors
um
and then I'm going to unalive myself
right afterwards as a protest because
Dwayne The Rock Johnson doesn't he have
enough money
someone get to him and tell him that
this is crap
uh I'm gonna try these ice creams
because they're insane swordstro is
always doing like this like they
have olive oil flavor like olive oil and
goat cheese ice cream it annoys
everybody and it's wrong we've got 75
000 homeless people here now and I think
it's a little weird to have basil ice
cream and you know all that
so the first one I'm trying is uh
chocolate potato
uh salad and this is the mustard
flavored ice cream which I think is
probably heinous now it would be a great
bit if I ate four pints
like if I every single pint I just ate
the entire pint as I was talking about
how gross it is I was like this is
horrible but I am going to try this now
I don't know why you would even make
this kind of ice cream this is mustard
flavored ice cream with fudge and potato
chips in it
back up
it's not good
a knock-off that's not good
this is if you're listening to this this
is a visual gag
that was not good
I know that we were thinking like maybe
it would be good
not good now we're going to try cinnamon
and honey Fried Chicken
I don't know if this is going to be good
or not but
again not really
I gotta be honest
not really
they're just up over there it's
knock up
terrible
baked brie and fig cheesecake
again it's just oh it's something's
wrong
something is wrong it's just not it's
truly not great like you can try all
these like people in the studio you can
all try them
they're not that they're not that good
um they're they're not good
and then the last one is sour cherry pie
I imagine this is good or some type of
good
but who knows because salt and straw has
been up a long time because
Dwayne The Rock Johnson
you know is too busy endorsing uh Kamala
Harris and what he's not doing is his
mind's not on his business
that's not bad
um
foreign
my mother has passed away uh this is uh
something we should say and I should say
it
um uh while uh after I eat the ice cream
and it's very sad it was you know
obviously
um it's uh it's very new it's a new
development
um but she was suffering at the end of
her life and it's it's it's it's hard
when someone's suffering I've talked
about it multiple times
um we're cremated I'm not choking up I'm
coughing on the mustard ice
cream it's literally heinous it's
heinous
um we're cremating her because that's
what she wanted
um and and we're and I I and she we're
scattering her ashes
and
she loved Hawaii
this is a fact she went to Hawaii as a
young person all the time
I'm asking a question I'm asking a
question now I'm asking a question I
don't know if this is the case
is it bad taste
if I go to Maui
with an urn of my mother's ashes
and scatter them in the ash
that is is that wrong
or is it beautiful
is it actually beautiful
or are the people going to get mad at me
if I do that I mean serious question are
the people
going to get mad at me because
apparently their tragedy is the only
tragedy we have to think about right now
right
but I think if I went there with ashes
and I would say that to them I would say
I'm here with my mother's ashes in
Maui
and I'm here to just
I'm here you know and they're gonna and
I'm not here to help
and I I'm glad there are people that are
there to help but I'm not there to help
because I got my own thing
I got my own thing and I imagine the
Four Seasons is unaffected this is what
we've Googled and I would stay there of
course but I and I just want to know is
that a bad look
if I go
to Four Seasons with my mother's ashes I
don't know
uh salt and straw stop doing this
with the summer flavors they are heinous
you know they're not good the sour
cherry pie is good